Our Father in Heaven as I try in my
human way to answer questions let your
spirit direct my mind I pray bless us
all with truth in Jesus name
amen hi so I've been contemplating many
people attend church but they cannot
defend the doctrines in their churches
most of the time if you ask them what
they practice in their churches what it
means and why they do it they will
literally fail to answer you at most
they will tell you let me get back to
you let me go and ask my papa my priest
or my pastor and we all know most of the
times they never get back to you but
church should not be taken like that you
see as a church member you need to
understand what you're practicing why
you're doing what you're doing and if
anything you need to question the
doctrines in your church and how they
stand when put next to the Bible because
everything that is taught in church is
supposed to agree with what the Bible
teaches if it does not agree with what
the Bible teaches you could be in a
wrong church now most of our churches or
rather most of the churches have got
some form of Bible commentary in our SDA
we've got writings by L G white which
are very educative and I would encourage
every SDA member to at least have a book
of L G white and read read it you see
also do not only be preached on by your
pastors and your priest sometimes put
them to task have a question and answer
session where you ask them things that
you do not understand in the Bible and
also some of the things that your church
could be accused of so that you have a
learning and an understanding of what
your church is where it's taking your
faith and you have a basis on which to
answer all accusations that are piled
upon you as a church member of your
church now without further Ado here is a
question and answer session by Pastor
Randy kit of which he answerers some
very four good and important questions
question number one is was madc a god
number two is is the sdh chur a c number
three is did Jesus Christ die a second
death and number four there are people
who say give me Christ but keep religion
so here you have it our father in Heaven
as I try in my human way to answer
questions let your spirit direct my mind
I pray bless us all with truth in Jesus
name amen before I take your questions I
want to deal with one or two that have
come to me over time one of them is is
mlisc
Christ or is mlisc God I've have heard
that over and over some people believe
mzc is Christ let's take a look
reasonably the Bible says come now let
us do what reason together the Bible is
not a book of proof it is a book of
evidence where there's proof there's no
need for Faith where there's evidence
faith is required but Faith biblical
faith is not blind the evidence of the
Bible points in a certain direction and
if someone reads it honestly that person
will follow that direction all right
let us go to Deuteronomy
18 for answer the question is melis
Christ in case you fall asleep let me
tell you no immediately but let's go to
Deuteronomy
18 while you're looking for Deuteronomy
18 tell me the three offices of Christ
Prophet priest is that the
order yes when he came he was a
right now he's a eventually he'll be a
all right we're looking at his role as a
prophet Deuteronomy 18 we read from
verse 15 when you found it say Amen am
read with me what does that say the Lord
thy God shall raise unto thee of thy
Brethren a prophet like unto me him he
shall hear Moses prophesied that God
will raise up a prophet to his people
like
Moses notice he said like unto me so
Moses is saying I am the
type you not with me like unto me so I
am a type and whoever he is will be the
antip go to Acts chapter
3 by the way God bless all the children
who gave the verses thank you very much
and continue to read God's word and love
it and the adults thank you as
well acts 23 not not 23 sorry Acts 3 we
read 22 and
26 read with me what does it say for
Moses truly said unto the fathers a
prophet shall the Lord your God raise up
unto you come on of your brethren like
unto me does that sound familiar yes
he's quoted from Deuteronomy 18:15 Now
read 26 un you first God had raised up
his son Jesus sent him to bless you now
who is the prophet Moses spoke about
Jesus which means the prophetic model
for Christ work as a prophet was
Moses I didn't say that clearly let me
say differently the the Old Testament
type of the prophetic Ministry of Christ
was
Moses go to the Book of Luke chapter
1 Luke chapter
1 and Moses was not
God you have Luke 1 this is the Angel
telling uh Mary about the son she would
have let's read verse 32 the angel
Gabriel is speaking to Mary a shocked
Mary you have 32 read with me and he
shall be
uhhuh the son of the highest and the
Lord shall give unto him come on the
throne of his father David the Lord
shall give unto him when Christ finally
sits enth throned he will be sitting on
the throne of his father David go on
next verse and he shall House of for and
of his kingdom they shall be so this
kingship will last forever it's the
kingship of David that Christ will
inherit now the Old Testament type of
Christ's kingship is whom David's
Ruth David's rule is the Old Testament
type when Christ sits on the throne it
will be the anti Tite the Fulfillment he
will reign
forever go to Hebrews 5 and David was
not God
Hebrews
5 and it's also mentioned about three
times in chapter
7 let's read N9 and 10 of Hebrews 5 what
does that
say and being made perfect he became the
author of Eternal salvation unto that
pause a minute unto all them that obey
here that I want to
digress obedience is to set aside in
this modern world we are too offended by
the word obey Christ is the author of
Eternal salvation unto them that obey
him go to acts 5 quickly as I still
digress Acts chapter 5
let's read this is Peter speaking to the
Sanhedrin they they were surprised that
those guys were still preaching about
Jesus now let's read verse 32 here's
what Peter says of Acts chapter 5 read
with me and we are his Witnesses of
these things and so is also the Holy
Ghost whom God hath given to them that
obey
him Jesus is the author of salvation to
those that
obey the Holy Ghost is given to those
that obey
him amen I just wanted to stress obey
now we get back to Hebrews 5 let's read
N9 again and being made perfect he
became the author of Eternal salvation
unto that o read verse 10 now called of
God I praise after the order of Mel now
after the order is no different from
Moses saying light unto me are you with
me light unto me is the same as after
the order now the Old Testament model
for the priesthood of Christ is whom
meus let's review the Old Testament
model for Christ's prophetic Ministry
was Moses and Moses was not God the Old
Testament model for the kingship of
Christ was David and David is not God
the Old Testament model for his
priesthood is why should MC be God if
any one of the three Moses mesc David
had to be God it should be David I'll
tell you why because Christ's ministry
as a prophet it
ended it ended when he left this Earth
he's no longer Prophet what is he now a
priest will that end yes will his
kingship end no
so if one of the three had to be a god
it should be David not mesc because what
he symbolizes will end when we hear the
Declaration he that is Holy let him be
holy still melchisedec is not God people
think he is simply because his genealogy
is not recorded but the fact that
something is not recorded does not mean
it doesn't exist let me give an example
of that go to Psalm
106 Psalm 106
you have Psalm
106 read verse 17 for read 16 and 17 of
Psalm now Psalm 106 is called a
historical Psalm also Psalm 105
10778 136 they are historical Psalm they
all deal with God's interaction with the
Israelites from Egypt to the promised
land now Psalm
10616 what that say they envied Moses
also in the camp and Aaron the S of the
Lord the word envy mean they challenge
his
leadership who challenge his leadership
Kora come on Dayan come on and a those
three read verse 17 the Earth open and
swallowed up
uhhuh what do you
notice Kora is not mentioned but if you
read number 16 Kora went down with them
so when if Kora is not mentioned you
simply fill in the
light based on other information go to
number
16 number
16 let's read from verse
one book number four
numbers you have that read with me now
Kora the son of isar the son of Kath the
son of Levi and Dean and abon the sons
of elab and on the son of PB sons of
Reuben took men and they Rose before
Moses with certain of the children of
Israel 250 princes of the assembly
famous in the congregation men of renown
and they gathered themselves together
against Moses and against aod and said
unto them ye tap too much upon you
seeing all the congregation Are Holy
every one of them and the Lord is among
them wherefore then lithy up yourselves
above the congregation of the Lord and
when Moses heard it he set upon his fish
now Kora daan and Abra those three when
you read Psalm
10617 that the Earth opened up and
swallowed death and a birum the author
simply perhaps just forgot to write Kora
but you have to know where you see Dayan
and abam
let me give you an
example of non- mention does not mean
nonexistent are you with me the fact is
not mentioned does not mean it doesn't
exist go
to Genesis 14 no no no not Genesis 14 go
to Jude verse 7 the book of Jude is
found just before Revelation and just
after
third son
okay give you a little headache there
for a minute were F in the country as F
they're well known yes well known well
respected mhm within the yes yes MH mhm
It's usually the influential people who
cause trouble all right do you have Jude
yes verse 7 let me pray again father
continue to speak to us clearly in Jesus
name I pray amen read with me even as
Sodom and gorah and the cities about
them in like manner give themselves over
to fornication and going after stra
flesh as set for for an example
suffering the Vengeance of Eternal now
when you think of wicked cities who
comes to mind yeah throughout the S but
there were five of them yes there were
read verse again seven even as sod andar
care now and the cities about them in
like manner just is wicked but the Bible
writers don't want to keep saying Sodom
Gomorrah
ad so they pick two these represent the
wicked cities of the plain the same way
go and neog represent All Nations
opposed to
God but you can't list all of them so go
and MOG represents All Nations opposed
to God let me give you a practical
example what state are we in Tennessee
all right now I am going to ask you to
identify
state but I'll only mention some
cities and you tell me what state I'm
thinking of are you with me are you
ready
Nashville do I need to name all the
cities in Tennessee no when you hear
Nashville you hear Tennessee are you
with me when you hear Sodom andorah you
hear adma Zabo and Bella now go to
Genesis
14 so don't believe because something's
not mentioned it doesn't exist
it must have a prior existence somewhere
in the Bible and does not need to be
repeated over and over again Genesis 14
we read from verse
one are you there read with me now it
came to pass in the days Amel king of sh
AR king of ala K king of Elam Untitled
king of Nations carefully now that these
made war with Bearer king of Sodom and
with Bersa king of gorah shyam king of
adma shimba king of Zabo and the king of
ba which is zor now how many cities
five five all five were Wicked we know
that from Jude verse 7 even as Sodom and
deorah and the cities about them in like
manner when you read the Bible use this
you're Noggin you ever heard the word
Noggin this and
concentrate now the fact that M merus
genealogy is not mentioned does not mean
he did not have good afternoon yes
sister Cal how is good AR no
complaints um what is your understanding
on the matter of if Jesus had died the
second death or not okay if what is my
understanding of if Jesus died the
second death or not the Bible says the
wages of sin is death the soul that
sinth it shall now did Lazarus die did
he come back did he die again now do you
come back from the death that is the
punishment for sin no now how Christ
came back that's mystery of mysteries
Christ died the death that is the
penalty for sin Lazarus died the death
that is the consequence of sin do you
understand the difference there's a
death that's the consequence of of sin
there's a death that's the penalty for
sin no living being outside Christ has
ever paid that penalty so Christ paid
that penalty in some mysterious way he
came back to apply the benefits of that
Victory to us so that's the death that
Christ paid not the one Lazarus died
people die all the time no you see if it
was the death Lazarus died then he died
for his own sins are you following me
Paul would to die for his own sins only
Christ has tasted that death for every
man according to Hebrews 2:9 and he came
back conquering death because the great
enemy is death The Last Enemy that shall
be destroyed is death all right thank
you
yes Lazarus died what twice yeah Lazarus
died
twice if lazarus's death is a penalty
for sin then he didn't pay
or he paid it for himself are you
following me only Christ can pay the
penalty for sin the death we die is the
consequence of being limited or finite
anything finite must
die you looking at me
strangely all right anything let me make
it clearer for you anything finite
touched by sin Must Die not only people
including the
world yep what of the Bible Hebrews 1
you don't believe but I'm glad you don't
so you can go to the Bible Hebrews
1 let's read from verse 10 this is God
the Father
speaking Hebrews 1 verse 10 to 12 read
microscopically when you found it amen
now remember this is God the Father
speaking to the son interesting Exchange
and thou Lord come on in the beginning H
has laid the foundation of the earth and
the heavens are the work of thy hand so
we have Earth and we have Heaven do you
see the word beginning yes now say
Genesis 1:1 for me in the beginning God
created the Heaven and the Earth so
that's Genesis 1:1 Now read verse 11
they shall yeah but thou now wait a
minute now if they perish it means they
are
limited the opposite of that is Christ
but thou remainest what is God saying
about
Christ he's
Eternal they Shall Perish but thou
remainest and they all shall wax old as
a the Garment and as a vesture verse 12
shall thou fold them up and they shall
be changed but thou are the same and thy
years shall not fail Christ is eternal
but his creation cursed by sin will
perish anything touched by sin
must cease to
exist but is a human being or the entire
world this world if it lasted long
enough must
self-destruct Revelation 211 and I saw
what a new Heaven and a new why a new
Heaven and a new Earth the old ones have
to be destroyed because they are tainted
by sin this body has to be be destroyed
it is tainted by
sin the reason why the only thing that
goes from Earth to Heaven is our because
the character form like Christ is not
tainted by
sin now the death Lazarus died was not
the penalty for sin because he would
have paid for his old and you can't do
that only Christ can do that the Death
Christ tasted was the death the second
death has mentioned in Revelation 20 a
few times all right uh who is come to
the mic come to the mic let's sayar the
quality of your voice hello I don't know
how you do it I got nervous just walking
it's all right but God is good yes he is
um I have a question what would you say
to someone who says that they don't want
religion but they just want a
relationship with God all right okay go
to Matthew 16 I've heard that before I
want a relationship I want no religion
all right go to Matthew
16 you have Matthew 16 we read the
passage as familiar let's read verse 16
when Jesus said but whom do men whom do
ye say that I am read verse 16 what does
that
say Simon Peter answered and said what
thou are the Christ the son of the
Living God keep reading Jesus answered
and said what Thou Art Peter blessed
thou Simon bar Jonah of Flesh and Blood
hath not revealed unto thee but my
Father which is in heaven go on I say
unto thee now and Upon This Rock H wait
a minute now and Upon This Rock come
on CH does God have a church does he
have a religion yes you cannot separate
God from his
religion go Ephesians 5
listen to Christ in the church Ephesians
5 let's read from verse 25 that's a very
good question by the way I've heard it
give me Jesus Keep
religion Jesus has a religion and it
comes with him you have Matthew 5 not
Matthew sorry Ephesians 5 read from
verse 25 with me husbands love your
wives even as Christ also love the
church now we have the Christ's love for
the church as the model of the husband's
love for wife so keep the church in mind
and gave himself for it that he might
sanctify and cleanse it with the washing
of Water by the word that he might
presented himself a glorious church not
having spot or wrinkle or any such thing
but they should be holy and without
blemish so ought men to love their
wives at the own B keep reading he that
loveth him for no man ever yet it his
own flesh but nourisheth it and cherish
it even as the Lord the church so it's
we're understanding how Christ loved the
church now read the next verse for we
are members of his body of his flesh and
of his
bones next
verse this is a great mystery but I
speak concerning Christ come on and the
church when you come to Christ you
become a member of his
church you cannot have Christ and not
his
sech go to Acts chapter
7 gu the word religion is give us a b it
has a yes the word religion has a bad
name and it's not God's
fault it is not God's fault the word
religion has a bad name do you have Acts
chapter 7 read verse 38 for me listen
very carefully and see if you find what
I think you should find read for
me this is he that was in in the church
in the wilderness stop to whom is the
author of Acts
referring the the Wilderness in the the
church in the
wilderness the church in the
wilderness the
Israelites and they are called by L what
a
church now let Exodus tell us the same
thing even though the word church does
not show up go to Exodus 19
you cannot have Christ and not his
church there's his church is his
representative on the face of the Earth
and you disregard Christ's Church you've
disregarded Christ and we'll see that in
a minute do you have Exodus 19 let's
read from verse 4 read with me what does
it say ye have seen what I did unto the
Egyptians and how I bear You On Eagle's
Wings and brought you unto myself now
there therefore if you will obey my
voice indeed and keep my Covenant then
you shall be a peculiar treasure unto me
above all people for all the Earth is
mine next verse and ye shall be unto me
come on a kingdom of priests come on and
a holy nation stop that's the church the
entire nation was to be a church and
Luke properly calls them a church
amen the word Church in the New
Testament Ecclesia means called out cor
Christ has a people whom he has called
out he separated from the world
according to El white how does you
separate them the messages of the first
second and third angels to have Christ
is to have his church now Christ may
have to lead you to that church you may
just meet him not realizing he has a
church but if he controls your life he
will lead you to his church and his
church respects all 10 Comm
fers who's next F the faith yes I'd like
to yeah if you allow if yeah have you
noticed lately that the Seventh
Adventist Church has been swirling
around in a lot of different circles in
terms of being cultish in terms of uh
even I think yes a couple days ago um
there was a certain person that a
certain um journalist that said that
Ellen White and the Seventh Day
Adventist Church are the cause for the
dietary the bad dietary that system that
we have in America oh have you know that
okay today so so when you hear these
type of things and the fact that the
seven Adventist Church is a cult how
would you then defend that what process
would you go through in terms of
Defending well as for the charge of
being a cult is very simple what is a
cult a cult is a group that is that that
rotates around one charismatic
person and that person exercises
dominance over the group literally tells
the group what to do and what not to do
a cult is built around one person
whether it's David Kesh who perish in
the Flames or somebody else the 7 ADV
church is not built around one person at
all the SE Adventist Church believes in
Jesus Christ as Savior Cults do not
believe that and so we're not a cult we
are I don't want to say we're mainstream
either because we're supposed to be
different from every other church on the
face of the Earth but with respect to
the secular definition of cult the 7
adven church is not a cult it is not it
does not revolve around Ellen White it
revolves around Jesus
Christ and the Bible is it's it's it's a
book of reference the Bible thus said
the Lord is our Authority now the Bible
is not the Authority for the Catholic
church so you want to call somebody a
call the Catholic Church a it revolves
around the pope not the same day adst
church we are built around Jesus Christ
and thus saith the Lord not around Ellen
White or Jane Andrews or whomever else
ad Jones
okay and by the way in the 50s a uh
Evangelical scholar studied the
Adventist Church he came he met forgot
Martin was his name and he met with high
ranking Adventists in the general
conference to answer this particular
question he was writing a book on cults
and he came away with the conclusion the
assembly Adventist Church is not a cult
all right uh yes now Pastor Randy kid
did a good job of answering all the
questions and I like how he answered
them basing off of the Bible therefore
whether you are SDA or not it should be
able to benefit you because as long as
you're a Christian and you use your
Bible for learning you should have
benefited from this anyway brothers and
sisters if you enjoy what you found in
this channel consider subscribing a like
to the channel will be appreciated thank
you and on to the next one